i made the mistake of going on the
internet once and going like hey i don't
see why
spider-man no way home couldn't have
been one of the 10 movies nominated for
best picture not even like should win
just i don't see why we got 10
nominations and i got dragged for a day
on social media where people were like
you should have died in that heart
attack
can you imagine hey gq it's me kevin
smith and today we're going to talk
about comic book movies and the comic
book characters i love
[Music]
when you say to me who is spider-man i
don't know that anybody leaps to mind my
take on the original spider-man movies i
thought toby maguire did a really good
peter parker but he wasn't quippy enough
as spider-man and i thought andrew
garfield was an excellent spider-man but
his peter parker was dare i say it too
sexy anyone would date andrew garfield
you know peter parker that's that's a
problem in his life nobody really wants
to date him and stuff so i think tom
holland for me
has encapsulated peter parker and
spider-man in the way that i prefer to
see him portray he looks the age looks
age-appropriate like toby always looked
older to me and he's
soft peter parker is like a little soy
boy he's soft right super smart but he's
like totally soft soft enough that the
death of uncle ben
changes the course of his existence
where he's like i'm gonna dedicate my
life to fighting crime i'm poor but i'm
smart and i know how to build web
shooters and stuff i could develop these
things but like i let a guy go and that
guy killed my uncle never again hands
down i feel the best spider-man movie
ever made is spider-man into the
spider-verse absolutely captures
everything about both peter parker and
miles morales who came years later my
favorite moment in that movie though
belongs to chris pine who plays the
iteration of spider-man who spoilers
dies in the beginning he has this moment
where he's very
you know pithy and blithe and cracking
wise while he's fighting this gigantic
version of the green goblin
but then when he's finally felled he's
tired and he's broken and you could tell
he's on the ropes and he's just like
okay
i just need a second i always get up i
always get up he's talking to miles
morales and he says we gotta team up
he's like you gotta take this thing you
gotta stick it in that thing blah blah
blah
and then he gets so serious i might cry
like talk about he gets so serious where
he goes
listen you wear a mask you don't let him
know who you
are you need to hide your face you don't
tell anyone who you are
no one can know he's got everyone in his
pocket what if he turns the machine on
again everything you don't disappear
your family everyone and it's so like
there's a moment it's just 10 seconds
that puts the gravity of the situation
we just watch this [ __ ] fight a
giant oversized beast as like you know a
transport interdimensional device is
going on and [ __ ] like that there's
threats everywhere but that 10 seconds
where he warns the kid to hide his face
which makes mask wearing makes sense
this moment in spider-man
captures perfectly the threat
at the center of every superhero's life
which is like i'm going to do the right
thing and in doing so
i'm gonna put everyone i know at risk if
they know who i am
i thought that moment was profound
sometimes i just roll that smoke weed
watch that moment and just go yes
[ __ ] yes like they stuck the landing
on that very moment the rest of the
movie could have sucked and that moment
would have redeemed it all but the whole
movie is fantastic you want to talk
about people who understand spider-man
and the spider-man mythos oh watching
spider-man into the spider-verse is an
exercise
in fan appreciation
and
abject jealousy because i'll never write
something as beautiful as that
it's a story that everyone could get
behind right because who are they
they're outsiders and everybody in this
world i don't care if you're the
ultimate insider sooner or later you
feel like an outsider sooner or later
you feel castigated by society sooner or
later you feel like the other and this
is a story that encapsulates that this
is a story about a bunch of others who
have these secret powers and the world
don't want them around we don't want
your kind of dirty mutants and stuff you
know it's a very it's an allegorical
title to say the least but
it also has wolverine which is just
badass character guy that you know
snicked and the claws come out and
he slices and dices you
look this is why i love comic books
plain and simple they are simple
parables
about the worst thing in the world ever
happening and everybody is running from
it like crazy as they should responsibly
and then there's one person or a small
team dressed very colorfully heading
straight
toward it like i'll read that story from
now
until the end of time man and the x-men
encapsulate that even though society
doesn't respect them they reject them
completely charles xavier and his x-men
still go out and protect humanity from
the worst threats sometimes mutants
sometimes not mute there are mutants out
there with incredible powers logan
and many who do not share my respect for
mankind
if no one is equipped to oppose them
humanity's days could be over so they
dominated the 90s and the arts in the
comic book marketplace and they're set
to dominate the comic book marketplace
again now that kevin feige and marvel
studios have their hands on the x-men
characters and all the x-men ip that fox
used to have by themselves they made
some wonderful movies over fox about the
x-men but now we're going to see them
brought into the marvel studios man the
marvel cinematic universe so the x-men
can be side by side with spider-man with
thor with iron man is a great day for
those of us who love
to keep our universes together i can't
wait for the day that dc and marvel
fight each other and it will happen one
day chris claremont who is a brilliant
writer and created most of what we know
and love about the x-men was writing an
epic that you couldn't just jump into it
was one of the few comic books that you
couldn't just pick up be like oh i know
the story now it was so involved so
fraught so
big well of course we all love
wolverine's very cool idea and he's
canadian that makes me love him even
more i'm not canadian i'm just a big fan
of canada big canada file and stuff but
i'm big cyclops guy to be honest with
you the idea that ruby quartz visor
always captured my imagination this guy
has to wear these glasses for the rest
of his life if he takes him off he has
no control of these lasers that shoot
out of his head
he can't even
look into the eyes of jean grey
the woman he loves without possibly
killing her there's a really beautiful
moment one of the x-men movies i forget
which one it is where he takes off his
glasses for one second and she sees his
eyes and it's like oh it's incredibly
moving
scott summers man he's also he's the
dante of the x-men universe like dante
from quick stop and clerks just put upon
has to carry everything he's not even
supposed to be there that day and stuff
and you're competing with wolverine for
the affection of your girlfriend
good night logan you know not that gene
shows much interest in wolverine beyond
a friend but you constantly got the
threat of wolverine at your back not as
an enemy is going to cut you up but as
somebody who's like you know i'm
stealing your girl you're going to tell
me to stay away from your girl well if i
had to do that she wouldn't be my girl
well then i guess you've got nothing to
worry about do you
cyclops
[Music]
the incredible hulk to me will always be
lou ferrigno
because i grew up watching lou fergunon
tv you have to realize how special it
was to have a comic book tv show you
know nowadays turn on disney plus and
they start a new one almost every week
back then we didn't have a lot of
choices and there was a character on a
tv show called the incredible hulk who
looked like the incredible hulk
[Applause]
[Music]
you know they changed bruce banner's
name dr david bruce banner they made him
david because i guess they felt bruce
sounded too soft for the 70s so they
altered his name but everything about
else about him was accurate so lou
ferrigno
is a guy just painted green and he's
there you know don't get me wrong all
the visual effects they do with the
current day hulk is amazing but he's
tactile he's a guy crashing through a
wall with green paint on him you could
see him and stuff and you know in our
childhood that was enough we were never
like the hulk should be bigger like we
were like oh my god look at the hulk
he's amazing
so yeah lou ferrigno will always
be my hulk that being said like i think
ruffalo doing a bang-up job he's the
best
bruce banner for my money
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry
poor eric bannon man like
every movie he's in it looks like this
could be huge and then it like
doesn't quite connect he's such a
wonderful actor he was good really good
but for me ruffalo's really doing it and
ed norton i thought was really good too
and brought some cool ideas to the
character
but
ruffalo has the kind of requisite
sweetness as well you know at the center
of bruce banner's character in the
comics at least
is somebody who's trying to do the right
thing i put the brains and the brawn
together and now look at me
best of both worlds you know in the
comic books there's a gamma bomb test
that they're doing and rick jones you
know kid is out in the testing field and
bruce banner goes to save his life and
push him like into a trench to save him
from the blast and that's how he gets
hit
with the gamma bomb and that's what
turns him into the hulk so he's got a
compassionate heart at his center and we
all know that mark ruffalo seems to be a
pretty compassionate guy as well
thank you for having me gq
to the five folks at gq thanks for
having me those were my fine points